des convois humanitaires qui ne sont pas
sans risques c'est précisément dans
cette zone d'un journaliste français a
trouvé la mort hier alors qu'il
accompagne et justement des civils à
bord d'un convoi humanitaire fred avec
leclerc imhoff il avait 32 ans il
couvrait derrière la caméra ce conflit
pour bfmtv touché par un éclat d'obus
alors qu'il circulait à bord d'un camion
blindé de journaliste reporter d'image
est décédé sur le coup le reporter
maxime brandstetter qui l'accompagné lui
sain et sauf notre équipe est longuement
ya rester à ses côtés écoutez le
témoignage de donnacha de la taloche
maxime brandstetter été le collègue et
le collègue de frédéric leclef rim of
qui a été tué hier il reste avec nous
dans le même hôtel ici à bruges qui
piaillent nous avons parlé avec lui
longuement il est évidemment
complètement sonné complètement choqué
mais je pense que c'était pas la peine
de s'étendre là dessus en tout cas il va
bien il a été très légèrement blessé et
la fixeuse qui travaillaient avec
l'équipe de bfm tv et oksana va
également va également bien elle n'a
elle n'a aucune blessure concernant les
circonstances
de la mort du journaliste de bfm
frédéric leclerc imhof les choses sont
aujourd'hui assez clair il était à bord
d'un véhicule blindé d'un camion blindé
de la police qui n'était pas encore allé
cette chance qu'en réalité qui se
rendait à l'itie de chances que par
départ des routes et des petites routes
et des chemins de campagne que nous
avons nous même emprunté il ya deux
jours c'est effectivement une route très
dangereuse on entend les tirs
d'artillerie raisonner en permanence il
ya des panaches de fumée un peu un peu
partout sur la route donc tous les
journalistes qui se rendent à l'itie de
chance que son sont conscients du danger
et puis la ville elle-même qui est
voisine de severodonetsk
voilà elle et elle fait l'objet
d'intenses bombardements quand nous nous
y sommes rendus pour y tourner un
reportage on pouvait entendre des
détonations des déflagrations des des
tirs quasiment à chaque instant c'était
réellement très impressionnant